minutes or so and
[Music]
thank you so much also for being here uh
this is the last talk of the workshop
uh so please go ahead
sure uh hey everyone uh it was great to
be at the seminole center last year
um i was working on the smart contracts
for auckland uh before last summer and
it was continuing while i was at summons
our continued making progress and i'm
happy to
report uh our design and prototyping and
the interesting things that we found
um so this is john work with
maurice lihi victor la chanco
and luba shrira
speculative smart contracts
right so at the beginning of this year i
just
realized that the assets locked up in
the smart contracts mainly on ucrm
i exceeded 1 billion dollars in the
default markets
which was a all-time high and i think
during the summer uh this amount
has more than doubled although i
couldn't find
a consistent number about the weather is
three beating or eight
bidding or even more depending on the
source
uh but you get a sense that this is
really of
high stake now in terms of smart
uh smart contracts uh at a very high
and not so accurate level you can
imagine it as a vending machine
that a user could input
a dime and the machine doesn't have a
person operating but
has some built-in logic that would
recognize
input and the process and the return
so that for the user a smart
contract is not so different
in the sense that it operates on
uh some coins and the trees some tokens
or
crypto assets but the trading is
controlled by the
underlying logic not by people
what's different is the distributed
nature of
the smart contracts from a vending
machine
a vending machine is basically a single
machine perspective
but on the blockchains uh these
both the consensus and smart contracts
are governed
by some entities on the
blockchain and in the existing system
uh mostly smart contracts are executed
in the crypto uh critical path of the
blockchain
for generating blocks uh pictorially you
can imagine it like the following the
users would submit us
regular payments transactions and smart
contract transactions
um some blockchains have propagation
network some are via
private communication but the point is
that there will be a set of users
randomly selected or prefixed
those users are governing
the generation of the blocks and those
users
are also the ones that execute the smart
contracts code
with their virtual machine in operand
they are called consensus committee
some blockchains called miners
validators
will refer to them as consensus
committee
but you get their role and then those
committee will
finalize the outputs the states in the
blockchain
including both the simple payments and
the smart contract transactions
the smart contracts essentially encode
arbitrary user defined
code their size here the size is not
really bite-sized but the exclusion time
spent in terms of running them could be
much higher than the simple payment
the point is that here since they all
land up in the same way
simple payments are waiting for
contracts to finish execution and uh
therefore blocked by them it is like in
a supermarket uh instead of having
everybody shopping around
uh there is one entry an exit point and
the people need to go uh
so even if a buyer only wants a bottle
of water
he will still have to wait for another
shopper who has a
super long shopping list so this is uh
what's going on uh in today's smart
contracts
we have seen a search in the usage of
smart contract in d5
this causes congestions and the gas fee
has served i would like to turn this as
a good
problem to have this problem happens
because our popularity has
increased but because of this congestion
and high fees also the fluctuation of
the fees
making them unpredictable um we would
like to
uh address the problems from a different
approach which is
um in order to achieve scalability uh to
scaling the
uh the smart contract and without
affecting the blockchain's main block
generation
uh we're going to take a different
approach
and that different approach comes from
um our observation
that uh a lot of the smart contracts
existing today um do not need to be
processed or do not have to be processed
at least
namely the consensus protocol
and there are a lot of them forming a
long tail
for example there are contracts that are
too too big with dental data
intensive apps for example a private
security offering
that needs a large white list
know your customer database
may even have a blacklist database
um that can be huge um
some contracts may be too long uh
computation
intensive um a lot of cryptographic
applications would refer into this
category even though the execution times
have been increasing uh in the past
years
uh there's still a gap between how fast
they are
and what a normal operation would take
uh another category of smart contracts
uh probably something that is sort of
weird
in the sense that uh they come up is
come up
uh in other words like crypto
cryptokitties
according to kitties is sort of uh
non-fundable tokens but
not the standard ones uh they have uh
secret formulas about how
you know the dnas of the kitties could
uh mutate
and some intense computation involved
there were such popular application
and crashed its crm in
2017 but
researched suddenly and they almost
disappeared suddenly
it's hard to prepare for layer one to
predict
what would come like this and by the
time
people are prepared uh they probably
have disappeared too
another type of smart contracts that we
we find uh better not in layer one
are uh with software engineering efforts
some contracts functionalities are too
too complex
you may prefer to have a higher level of
language
instead of assembly level some
modularity would
be good to decompose the
tasks some involve different contracts
controlled by different entities
in order to engineer them
it is better to have a a well-supported
software engineering environment
rather than write directly in layer ones
probably lower level languages
so after we did a lot of investigation
about
existing smart contracts and thought
about
what's the best thing to do for scaling
um the solution we want to do is to move
the arbitrary
user-defined code out of the critical
path of the consensus protocol
and we are doing this by
having the smart contracts to be
speculatively executed
relative to some
snapshots of the blockchain and only
finalizing their effects
on the blockchain at a later time
so i'm going to briefly talk about
uh those three things one is
the architecture how to look like in
general
and one is um we'll dig deeper about
how a speculative virtual machine
would differ from a non-speculative
virtual machine
this is a single machine perspective
just from a single node
uh what should be done and then from the
distributed perspective um
how information is replicated and
communicated in a network
this is a different flavor from the
theoretical studies
in the sense that we are not proving
serums this is really a
cross-disciplinary
project with programming language
database disputes a little bit
distributed computation
uh formal verification so a lot of
different approaches from
rivers mathematical groups
so in terms of the overview let me first
say something about
what transactions are supported directly
in the layer 1 of operand blockchain
ethereum's blockchain supports simple
payment transactions
and everything else will need to be done
via
smart contracts support simple payment
transactions too
uh something like this alice is paying
five argos to bob
that's a payment transaction now operand
supports
some other components directly in layer
one for example atomic transactions
is a way for the user to specify that
certain actions need to happen
in an atomic way for example alice and
bob
want to do a a swap a
atomic swap um in serum they will have
to use
hash and time locks on operand
they would both sign such a structure
with two transfers and
the blockchain would treat it as you
know the first happens if and only if
the second happens
so this is considered as atomic
um there is also the layer one smart
contracts
uh which is designed to be a very
simple language a script a a stack
language
uh assembly level uh we call it two
transaction evaluation approval language
um the point is that it is uh it has a
small set of op codes
and it does uh basic things um so that
it does not become the bottleneck on the
blockchain
so you want a single transaction of the
following four that
it requires the execution of some q code
and it will only make the transfer if
the code returns
true or it could do some other state
changes for the blockchain
um i'm hiding some details here the
quote does not have to be part of the
transaction
the codes are stored in a account
in the database so that it is referred
to but not necessarily
included in the transaction this is a
simple
layer one layer one language
for uh basic smart contracts
and there are also layer one assets um
which is
at the same level as argos as you can
see are
i'm already using an example above like
these three usdc's uh from bob to alice
uh that is a layer one asset we can
directly refer to
and the blockchain state would maintain
their balances for the users
there are many other functionalities in
layer one for example users could
register deregister their keys
participating consensus protocol
but those things listed here are the
most relevant things
for the speculative smart contracts i'm
going to talk about
um the answer for the um user-defined
computation to be off-chain
uh the speculative structure would look
somewhat different
from the um previous picture you've seen
when it was unchained uh first of all
this is the part where users steal the
issue transactions to the blockchain
some are regular transactions some are
controlling call transactions
um the consensus support the consensus
committee
uh includes them in the blockchain
but here the difference is the following
that the consensus committee is not
executing the contract cost
the only thing they do is to register
the calls in the blockchain
to establish the common knowledge among
users that
those are the calls that have been
issued and need to be executed
they do something else one thing they do
for example
is that users would prepay the execution
fee at this stage so that would be
already
deducted here
it is a second off chain component that
would actually execute the cost
here there would be a new set of
contract committee
the selection here is similar to
consensus committee um
i will talk about that more later when
we get to the
distributed structure and here in
for a single node um
that belongs to the contract committee
uh it actually runs a vm
and it fetches the contract calls from
the blockchain
in a deterministic way here
simply first come first serve but you
can imagine other
uh other scheduling algorithms
could work too as long as is
deterministic
the virtual machine will execute with
respect to some
uh snapshots of the blockchain for
example here it
runs after block 2. uh it will generate
uh
effects that would be communicated to
the blockchain
the effect transactions are in
one-to-one correspondence with the car
transactions
and in a single order um
they are standard layer one transactions
um so here to process the effect
transaction the blockchain only need to
you know
if i transaction could be payments could
be creating assets uh closing accounts
so all the things that the layer one uh
supports directly
uh those effect transactions will be
communicated to the consensus committee
uh here via uh the underlying
propagation network
um then the consensus committee would
apply
the ether transactions to the blockchain
and uh include them in sleep block five
as a
you know a later time after block two
and continue with the regular
transactions
and in the meanwhile the virtual machine
is executing the contract as a consensus
committee continues to produce new
blocks so in this case two blocks have
been
produced in in the middle so this is a
high level structure
of the uh speculative architecture
now talking about the speculation
it's not a new concept say from
database processing and
it does not take people long to realize
that because the execution is
speculative
and blockchain is evolving there has to
be a window of
vulnerability what i mean is a following
that says the execution is done
after block 2 and the output of
execution is that
alice transfers 5 ago to ball
however when the fx appears in block 5
or the council committee tries to
include it in block 5
alice no longer has five argos therefore
that either cannot happen
and there have to be other consequences
about
what's the fate of the smart contract
this contract called
so what about the progress because those
things can be
declined by layer one
here again this is not serum proving but
this is
uh really principles that
if we think about speculation it already
happens in real life
uh well database is very familiar with
speculation
but if you think about in real life when
we write a personal checks
uh it takes a while for the checks to be
uh
to be deposited and the balances could
change
and the checks could bounce but people
will understand these things and that's
why personal checks
are used to be so popular because
compared with
uh you know cashier checks which is
guaranteed to not bonds
and personal checks does have the
advantage of being
you know asynchronous being very
flexible to issue
and you do not need to wait in line in
the bank to get the cashier checks
another thing that everybody understands
is that
don't write personal checks exceeding
your balance
in the previous case example alice would
have to issue payment transactions
individually from her own account
for her balance to drop below that five
hours
and another point another observation
worth mentioning is that even in later
one without smart
without without smart contracts in layer
one speculations are already there
this is true for every system where
transactions are
asynchronously issued but are cleared
in a sequential manner
and that because there is a gap
between at the point when a user sends
out a transaction
and when the point that a transaction
comes on chain
the one user issued a transaction he
checks the block snapshot
and be sure that okay the transaction is
valid
but the block state may change in
between
and if the transaction depends on the
state
that has changed then there will be a
chance that the transaction will not be
finalized
let's solve for payment because payment
really the individual user has to
send more payments but more so for smart
contract
uh transactions if it depends on some
states that have changed
we rarely notice this
uh for example uh when the chain is slow
right there the state changes are slow
and
rare and when there are not too many
transactions
because uh not so many of them would
have changed the underlying blockchain
state
but it is it would be uh it has been
more noticeable
uh when the chain itself is fast and
or or sometimes when a chain is
congested therefore it takes a long time
for the transaction to be finalized and
the more this happens
more likely that the transactions may
bounce
even in their way
so the point that people have learned
is how to make your transaction really
uh not
bounce uh first of all don't write bad
checks
uh because only you can move your assets
um don't depend on voluntary
state um this relates to
how people write their smart contracts
and what contract
a user would want to call to check that
the contract state
do not change fast and are not affected
by too many accounts
and a good idea is to use escrows as
needed
uh for example uh 96 controlled escrows
can be used when several parties want to
use the same smart contracts
and uh script controlled accounts is
something that the algorithm provides in
their own
that we can have a piece of teal code
that
governs uh transfer in and out of
a account that's another way of doing
escrow
so bottom line is that there are there
are speculation
but speculation failures are
easy to avoid um when people know
uh what to look at
okay so that is a bit of overview of the
uh oral architecture and uh
let's dig a little bit into the single
machine view
from the virtual machine from a single
node perspective
so this part i i would talk a little
about
the actual language grammar
but i would focus on more about take
a non-speculative virtual machine what
components needs to be added or changed
uh in order for it to support a
speculative
execution so this paradigm allows
gives us a fair amount of flexibility
so that uh the underlying virtual
machine doesn't
really you know it's pretty agnostic
with underlying virtual machine
and the programming language um so we
can take uh whichever language we prefer
and build those components on top
uh the first thing is some on-chain
predicate
and the second is about issuing
blockchain
actions those are about how the layer
two
interacts with layer one and the third
is about
the storage structure how would the
story change in order to support
speculation
um the best way to understand
entrepreneurs
is to uh show an example
so let's think about this type of smart
contract
uh automated market maker um uni swap
if you know what it is um so this is a
a machine that does exchanges from
europe
between euros and dollars and the
analysts insert
one euro and gets back 1.1 dollars
and that's because the machine keeps
track of the market's exchange rate
and when the execution extends
the rate was 1.1
um but in the automated market maker
um because of due to other people
may also be trading dollars and euros
the exchange rate may change from time
to time
as a different relative to different
blockchain snapshot it may determine
that
the rate is 1.09 for example
so what should happen if the exchange
rate has changed
since the speculative execution
now this is not a algorithmic question
this is really a policy question that
can be decided
by the developer of the smart contract
and that is where the ancient predicate
would come in
it provides the user a final little
power
about how whether the effects should
really happen on the blockchain
it looks like something like this so in
this atomic transaction where
the virtual machine outputs there are
two transfers
uh a euro from alice's contract account
and
1.1 from the contract to alice
and also it may include a piece of q
code
as predicate and the transaction would
be considered
valid only if the predicate executes
true
but as a point when it is actually
included in the blockchain
so let me give you three examples how
the product may look like for example
the developer
the writer of the smart contract may
decide that
i would only honor the user the exchange
rate at the speculation time
so i'm going to do the exchange anyway
in this case he doesn't need the
predicate
and from leader one's perspective
the reason why those two transfers
happen
is completely irrelevant you might only
know that
move uh coins from this account to the
other account
the end
of course this is uh simple but
this also does not give the users any
uh protection if the market is very
volatile that the exchange rate may have
dropped
to 0.5 and
the contract may not want to do the
exchange or it may change
to 2.5 and at least may no longer want
to do the change
another policy is following that the
developer could be very strict
i could see that i care about the rate
and i would only uh
want to do this exchange if the rate
remains exactly 1.1
so the predicator will do the equality
checking
and fail it if it changes at all
junior have a question so you say the
developer wants to be strict isn't it
more the user here
the user that is wishing to do a trade
uh it's a developer of this smart
contract
who is deciding what is the rules
in the predicate um so it is
like the service provider of this market
maker
is designing his policy about it
the users could accept the policy and
call it
or could not accept the policy
and does not want to use his service
i see the predicate then be somewhere
central wherever the smart contract sits
because here it kind of looks like it's
a specific choice attached to this trade
but instead it is more of a global
choice it is a global choice in this
case that it is part of the smart
contract's own code
that would specify how the product would
look like
um there is a different way uh there
in our extensions that's that's a good
question
in our extensions we are thinking about
um
giving the users also something what we
term as a post
condition so the predicate is sort of
determined by the smart contract but the
post condition
uh is something the users could provide
express the logic he wants it's not in a
prototype it may come
or may not come in the final version
that's the ongoing discussion
that's a good point uh
of course the third policy uh as another
example that's a developer that the
decision maker here who writes a smart
contract could decide that he wants to
give the user
some great syringe that uh
the exchange would still happen if the
rate has
it is in this 1.05 and 1.15
range but otherwise uh the exchange
should not happen
so this is divided by the smart
contract's own code
uh well many other things of course so
this is
how the uh on-chain predicate would work
uh in terms of the actual implementation
on the operand it would be uh
implemented
via the uh q script um
in a sense the following that the the
contract writer
will be writing the on-team predicate in
a smart contract language
that we provide and the interpreter of
the
language would turn the priority
into tube script and include it in the
transaction
of course there may be other
possibilities uh
any basic uh script language
should potentially work um for example
in serum
um there is a full-fledged evm
um i wouldn't recommend using the
fulfilled evm
as the uh ancient predator language
because that would mean that the
entrepreneur's execution cost
could be as high as uh any smart
contract
and that would still incur a high
layer one cost but
people could determine that the answer
predicate would only
allow a truncated semantics of evm
and com and and compile to steal the evm
language
but would only use a subset of its
semantics
and that would be totally considerable
if people want to do that
so any on-chain script would serve this
purpose
okay so that's about uh the predicate
and in terms of how the um speculative
vm
would communicate the output to the
layer one blockchain the difference is
mainly about
uh in a non-speculative vm
you can imagine the vm is directly
updating the blockchain states but
in the speculative vm it communicates by
issuing blockchain understandable
transactions
so example you know before the vm
execution alice has 100 argos and the
bob had 50 argos
let's say the vm's computation decides
that the bob is
paying five argo to alice in the
non-speculative version
the vmwould directly output a right set
uh saying that the alice now has 105 and
the bob had
45 but in this speculative version
uh it would issue a transfer transaction
that the blockchain would understand
uh five i go from oh i think i
i flipped the sender and receiver in
example it should be from bob to alice
and then layer one with the processor
transaction and make the state update
so this is um simple that we would need
to
install those transaction semantics into
the vm
so that uh whenever it tries to write
the blockchain state
here it uh issues transaction
uh that's uh well unders and pretty easy
understand
okay um the other part
is about storage um so this is a third
uh big component here
um in a non-speculative virtual machine
the solid structure looks like the
following the vm has a
internal memory um the memory needs to
handle
you know that's the function calls and
rollbacks of functions
this is particularly for smart contracts
where
function calling other functions are
allowed and you know internal functions
failing may not cause the entire
transaction to fail
and the outside caller may decide that
okay i'm going to handle the
internal functions error in some way but
i'm going to continue execution
but i want the internal uh changes made
by that function to roll back so map it
will understand
in uh transactional systems that
when nasa transaction could happen uh
we use stack structure and rollback
structure
in the uh vms manual
after that the vm will produce a reset
and the right set is directly uh going
into the
uh state database uh including the
blockchain database as well it just
didn't spell out
so that's right that's a two layer
uh structure from the vm to the db
now speculative uh vm is
similar in terms of the memory um
but it would write its changes
to a into a intermediate
uh speculation cache and not directly to
the db
um this is a temporary structure
that the purpose is that since the vm
may
execute say three contract call
transactions in a row
um the speculation cache should support
read my rights that the previous
contract changes should be reflected
here
then the second contract call would see
those changes and build based on that
but the speculation cache is short-lived
and after the effects transactions are
sent to the blockchain
this can be discarded and
up on the ifall transaction appearing on
chain
the right sets will be finally written
into the state theme
here the example does not show but
in case you know the second transaction
did not
commit on chain then the second right
set will not
be written to the final db if the third
transaction
is independent uh does not have an
overlapping you know
the reset does not overlap with the
right set then it can continue
commit otherwise it will have to be uh
re-executed
a second time so this is the speculative
structure with memories regulation cache
and
contract db so that's another component
that needs to be added
in terms of the vm storage structure
um there's there are some other
changes that uh i'm not going to mention
but
those are the you know uh the
interesting things that we realize
what's the difference between uh
speculation and non speculation
on the big components okay
um probably should
finish in the next five minutes or so um
last thing i want to talk about is the
distributed view of the speculation now
that
previously we talked about single node
view and here let's look at
what the contract committee does the
contract committee
uh in operand is selected in the same
way as the consensus committee
via vrf so it's they are
self-selected and their identities are
hidden
and huge they send out their voting
messages
uh it's based on proof stake
in very much the same way as a
consistent committee except
using different parameters and then at
different time points
so if you do not know that that
selection
is not really relevant um in other
blockchains
uh if if the blockchain is permissioned
it could also make the contract
committee permission as well
um so ginger question
so fees
for executing contract calls
are they shared between the consensus
committee and the contract committee
in that maybe i don't know the consensus
committee gets like a small cut
for including it in a block and then a
contract committee gets a better
a bigger cut for executing the actual
computation
um currently in the prototype we do not
do that um
we would rather uh reward the contract
committee or really compensate their
costs
via the execution fees um but the
consensus
committee uh would rather have a
separate
uh structure currently there is this
flat reward rate for everybody
and later we may introduce separate
incentives for them to do consensus but
would rather not
mix up those two um yeah
that instantly would get a pretty
complicated advice
a good question i should probably
mention that the fee is deposited as a
call
and if it's not entirely used up then
the final effect transaction would
refund the unused part back to you
let's just segment okay so for the
selection of the contract committee
um what is the condition
here the environment we want the
invariant
that we want to achieve is different
from the consensus here we only require
that
uh if enough contract committee has
voted
then at least there is one honest vote
instead of you know two thirds for
consensus for example
the reason is that um for the contract
committee
we only need to guarantee correctness
that the final result
is indeed that if you faithfully execute
the vm
presenting agreements are not needed
because the
uh contract committee is riding on the
back of the main blockchain
which achieves the balancing agreement
itself
now that has interesting consequences
which means that we can now tolerate in
a contract committee
a half militia stake rather than a third
as for visiting agreement
um that was a something that we realized
uh during our discussion but literally
we found that
we just reinvented the wheel now this is
not something new
in the uh you know distributed system or
balancing computation literature back in
2003
um people already pointed out
and that you know you can separate
uh execution from byzantine fault
tolerance
and one needs two thirds and one is a
half in terms of honest users
of course in their study there's nothing
about blockchain there's nothing about
the proof of stake it's purely
classic balancing environment
but it's the same principle here
um realizing that we
uh was pretty good uh because it
simplified the voting protocol
during our discussion there was a well
that was simply saying that oh the
contract committee could simply
reuse the consensus committees by the
agreement
and that's okay too because we can reuse
most of the system's code
um but then we realize we can actually
simplify the voting protocol a lot
there doesn't need to be a proposal and
so on uh i'll say a little bit next page
and uh what's more the committee size is
greatly reduced
uh from 2000 for the consensus protocol
to around 120 for the contract committee
um so this is
security against what what what is the
security guarantee for a dynamic
adversary
beside the 9th anniversary i want to
also mention
and validated dilemma which was pointed
out in the literature already that you
know if people vote
and somebody could simply copy the vote
without actually doing the work
that will diminish the purpose
here we have actually two different
contract committees
the validators they vote for the results
they execute the vms they vote for the
results um but they do not review the
content
voted up uh an
extra property is that the votes cannot
be copied without knowing the content
so they cannot just simply vote for
example for the
voting on the hash of the content that
would not reveal the content
but that vote can be easily copied
because another person can simply send a
hash
so here we can simply do that you vote
on the hash of the content
concatenated with this person's id to
just hide the pre image so that
the other person will not be able to
reproduce the hash
without seeing the content
now of course when there is enough vote
uh the content should be reviewed so
that people know
how to update the state database and how
to do the blockchain update
and that is done by the second set of
contract committee
called listeners um who
silently sit in their collecting votes
and the only job is to review the
content
uh upon seeing enough votes
so this is in the proof-of-stake world
where as long as
both have an honest user executing
then the uh contract will be correctly
voted
and uh the continent will be correctly
uh reviewed
it doesn't take long to realize that
this uh
this structure is also irreplaceable
in terms of you know as as in the same
same way as organs consensus protocol so
that a dynamic adversary
corrupting a validator will not affect
the listener's job
so um so put
everything together um the approach here
is
a mixture between on-chain
and off-chain solutions ancient would be
very simple
scripting language uh layer one assets
for simple problems
and uh all the complex user defined
computation of chain
uh speculatively uh
it leverages layer 1 structure for
atomic
state transition so that if the contrast
has more than one effect
we do want that all those effects are
installed in
a atomic way and as i mentioned
architecture is pretty much vm agnostic
um we can take a programming language
that we like and build on those
components to make it uh speculative
and in principle this does not even need
to be organ blockchain it could be
you know a speculative structure voted
on a different blockchain
and a particular bm
just some very quick words about what
kind of
language that we do want
uh we're collaborating with block stack
in terms of adopting or adapting their
programming language called
clarity and we do want the language to
be human readable
and has a modular structure
and it is interpretative so that it has
smaller trust base
you know strongly typed and with certain
safety checks
and static dependencies are very careful
about
dynamic dispatching and
the execution cost should be relatively
easy to estimate
so that's the type of language we are
currently working on
um as i said at the very beginning this
is a really
cross-disciplinary task and it involves
uh something from programming language
and
you know distribution and many other
different fields so it is a
very different experience here um
we finished the design and the prototype
and now we are working on building a
formal semantics for the underlying
virtual machine
and its ongoing work
all right i think with that i'll stop
here
and thank you for inviting thank you for
attending
other questions
it seems like uh seems like ali is gone
only offline yeah i don't know what
happened to him
okay i think we are out of time
also
okay well thanks jane uh thanks a lot
for coming and thanks for organizing the
workshop
okay